This autonomous car showcased at the 2013
Guangzhou Auto Show has a built-in fish tank.
And Javier Lloret created an interface called
Puzzle Facade that turned an entire building
into a giant interactive rubik's cube.
Vsauce!
Kevin here, this is Mind Blow.
Researchers have discovered that male Koalas
have a specialized sound-producing organ never
before seen in land-dwelling animal and it
makes the pitch of their mating calls 20 times
lower than it should be relative to their
size.
(Koala sounds)
So Yeah.
Swing over the edge of the world at La Casa
del Arbol in Ecuador.
The swingset allows people to feel like they're
flying off into an abyss at 2,660 meters above
sea level.
It's connected to a seismic monitoring station
that observes an active volcano nearby and
there's no harness or net or any safety precaution
whatsoever so riders use it at their own risk.
The Zeisel is an off-road wheelchair.
The year round all terrain vehicle is barrier
free and electric and it has the ability to
perform on snow, sand, mud, grass, and stone.
The battery lasts for several hours and it
tops out at 35 km/hour.
Ninja sphere connects all of your devices
in the home and is able to monitor temperature,
lighting, energy use, whether or not your
valuables are moving, and even your pets'
presence.
The project is open source so that anyone
can contribute with the hopes it will help
the Ninja sphere cover a wider array of devices
in the future.
New Wave Energy UK is looking to create a
high altitude aerial power plant.
Positioned at 50,000 ft unmanned aerial drones
will harness multiple forms of renewable energy
where wind patterns are more reliable and
solar energy is stronger.
There's also a smaller probability of weather
interference, so unlike green energy used
today such as windmills and solar panels,
there won't be downtime where fossil fuels
are relied upon as a backup.
This is a tiny dwarf seahorse catching a copepod
at lightening speed because their heads are
perfectly shaped to sneak up on prey.
The Hirose-Tanikawa lab is working on a mirror
that can change people's emotional states
by reflecting a different image of themselves
back to the user.
By taking a picture of the user's face and
subtly changing the expression to look happier
or sadder - they found they can change the
emotional state of the person looking into
the mirror.
And they hope to potentially use this in changing
rooms or department stores to alter your mood
while shopping or to help people struggling
with depression.
The last camera capable of capturing a single
pulse of light cost half a million dollars
to create and students at MIT recently created
one for just five hundred dollars.
Using the new time of flight camera you can
see light sweeping over the objects and eventually
lighting up the back wall.
They hope that in the future this nano photographic
technology can be used for medical imaging,
interactive gaming, and car safety.
Snow2 is a HUD for skiers and snowboarders
and comes equipped with Bluetooth and GPS
so that you can calculate your speed, keep
track of friends on the mountain, find your
way around, see the forecast, and view calls
and text messages all in real time.
Finally Void from Tundra is an audiovisual
installation that attempts to visualize the
idea of emptiness
I'm gonna leave you with a comparison of gravity
between Earth and Mars using a rover and a
banana.
Oh and also, Kevin.
I'm gonna leave them with something.
An illusion.
It's called Anomalous Motion - the image is
actually a still image but your mind think
it's moving.
I talk about why in my newest video over on
Vsauce.
But, Kevin.
Seventy five episodes of Mind Blow now?
Have you guys watched them all?
If you haven't - you probably should.
Yeah, there's a playlist at the top of this
video's description - (and) click that check
it out.
Well.
As always - thanks for watching.